I see it's got to be strange to see your
son playing you that has got to be an
incredible experience I'm sure but it's
got to be kind of a time warp it's got
to be very sick very weird
yeah Menace it's kind of like being in
that uh Back to the Future movie you
know what I mean yeah I thought I was
gonna change history if he came around
the corner I was like no put that hat on
before we disappear something yeah one
change too much you know I mean you know
che it's gotta be strange for you
because you got your dad looking at you
maybe telling you that's not how I would
have said that or I would have done that
was he already back off oh no he let me
you know spread my creative wings that
you know when when I got picked for the
role he really had to me off to the
director he would tell me stuff before
he's seen so I can ad-lib and things
like that but you know when the
helicopter dad another day that's good
you know what's interesting is you got I
mean I did a great job you have your
dad's scowl down you got you've got the
IceCube scowl down dude yeah we both see
the Saint the scallop time do it to
camera do it to camera six right there
[Applause]
you know what's great now is you have
your Christmas card yeah here
[Applause]
Merry Christmas [ __ ] you can't say
Merry Christmas [ __ ]